yeah welcome to this video first move
already played against key and go are
from Russia damn ok I had to slide
recently against you recoup I and
plundered I know I didn't blunder I mean
I i recently didn't make much of my my
chances let's see what happens here I
don't know the services rather dangerous
for black isn't it night 870 is he just
just retreating then no problem
ok
yeah but this isn't so terrible for
black I mean it's certainly a playable
position why does God bishops but then
other than that sir it's quite okay for
black solid I mean yeah how to play now
Bishop f4 and tending on let's let's do
this first against before you cannot
take of course on the phone just take
take it and play Bishop g4 then getting
e7 back at least okay Bishop 485 yeah
maybe if it opens up the position my
bishop won't seek to really belongs on
b3 on this open diagonal but he always
got 95 I want to play you five opening
it up open it up not opening it up or
maybe 22 group d one just centralizing
well he really don't doesn't want me to
play if I of it seems okay
hmm
I could take damage this bone structure
a bit but that's just centralized and
I'd c4 I've got to be should be three
don't think this is too terrible for me
hmm still could take it okay well this
piece build also be three anyway no used
to keep it there to cover to cover
before all the time now we 52 to open up
the position in five or is this
something else I come on e5 I've got
everything in the middle centralized so
this should be good really
mmm there should be six madre Bishop
takes Queen takes Queen d7 and that's
not a Queen f7 that's not really not
really on its playable but not winning
or anything need to be refined it's
wrong maybe maybe h4 h5
yeah the bishop won't be three is simply
better than the night
yeah taking on g6 and on e6 is some part
of the picture now he gave me the
default cannot play worked yet
this is very strange move why would hear
place himself right into the CAPTCHA
only six but okay maybe it is not a big
deal the trip is six Quinn texts got 97
okay so this isn't is it really on 97
and 97 is a good good defensive move how
to how to increase the pressure maybe
this way
yeah quindi 257 of my idea and also cook
h3 queen edge from
yeah this is a quite quite good I think
okay Queen age 6 25 okay then let's try
to get to d7
yeah it's still quite tough
I can go what Queenie seven yeah of
course wasn't exactly the refutation but
matter of matter of time and I must be
cautious this is one of those persons
playing look again throop with no pants
on time I lost a couple of games already
like this against them so I to try to
speed up a bit even if you don't play
the utmost precision news
you will play on time no doubt about
that
oh is this a draw already I just need to
click it I just need to click it yeah
because of the time it's probably am
it's probably equal anyway what worked
what else after this I need to do that I
have no other moves I certainly had a
great position I mean around here this
looks really good for white but maybe it
is not such a big issue you know this is
what the computer wants to do how do
like this right it's pretty it's pretty
solid still a form is the computer with
0.5 to white yeah interesting very
interesting game thanks for watching